Virginia Governor Ralph Northam declared
a state of emergency ahead of the storm
he joins us from Richmond governor good
morning I know that a mandatory
evacuation order has been issued for
about two hundred and forty-five
thousand residents along Virginia's
coastline our citizens heeding that call
well good morning and thank you for your
coverage yes they are heeding that
warning you
we have low-lying areas along our coast
very very vulnerable to storm surge and
you know I remind people it's certainly
the wind is a problem in these
hurricanes but it's the flooding it's
the rising seas that caused the loss of
life so we have four zones in Virginia
we have ordered a mandatory evacuation
of zone a we did that about 24 hours ago
and we're asking individuals that live
in that zone to go to higher land to
inland areas and and to be safe and they
are heeding the warning so thank you
that's a lot of evacuate but most people
don't have a second home people may not
have family in the area
do you have enough shelters well we have
a number of regional shelters and also
state shelters and and you know people
don't necessarily have to go very far
they just have to go inland and and to
higher land where they're safer because
there are some very low-lying areas in
in coastal Virginia those are the areas
that we worry about and we want people
out of those areas because we just can't
get to them if something happens
governor there's been a lot of rainfall
in Virginia this past year are there
areas of Virginia where people wouldn't
think that they were in danger where
they should think because of that
previous rainfall they are now in danger
well I would see along streams and
rivers that are at risk of rising and
and there the localities will let those
individuals know if they need to
evacuate so I just encourage every but
this is a very very dangerous storm and
I encourage everybody to stay tuned to
be vigilant and then to follow the
recommendations that we make I know but
governor you know there's always
somebody that says I'm gonna stick it
out I'm not leaving my house they are
here it's it's a monster it's vicious so
what do you say to those people to
really convince them and is there a
point of no return in your mind that if
you don't get out by X time forget it
well there is a point of no return and
when there's serious flooding we just
can't
get to those areas and you know I grew
up in on the coast I have watched
several of these hurricanes and I would
just ask these individuals to to pay
attention to listen to other folks that
have experienced this and to heed our
warning and don't take any chances this
is about life and death and we certainly
want to keep everybody in Virginia safe
yeah and you don't want to endanger
people we're trying to help you too
governor we thank you for taking the
time this morning we know you have a lot
going on we'll check in with you a
little bit later on I'm sure thanks a
lot sir thank you so much